this rally goes on every year or May Day
just been hearing about London about
global rallies in support of workers
rights and the French very vociferous in
their public discussions about workers
rights and of course have a long history
of organizing big protests like this in
in their cities but this year it is
different because a lot of the focus on
this is on one topic and that is on the
pension reform that president macron has
driven through which will raise the
retirement age from 62 to 64. and that
has brought people out on the streets in
a series of protests which is this is
the latest of them now there's going to
be a big one here in Paris 18 100 000
people on the streets but there are as
I'm Reckoning hundreds maybe 300
separate approaches going on in France
today big ones in cities like Bordeaux
and
or run Leon with the list goes on and on
and it is a reflection of huge growing
public discontent at two things one is
that simple moves to rotate to raise the
retirement age in a country where
workers rights are so Central to the
discourse that has gone down very very
badly I think for much of Europe and the
United Kingdom the idea of slowly moving
the retirement age up to 64 probably
seems not unreasonable whereas on macron
says that it is economically not viable
to maintain a low uh retirement age and
yet here you ask these people they think
well look at that 64 reasons of Fury
there is a feeling that this is just is
unfair and has broken that trust between
the people and their leader and that it
takes us to the second reason they are
so angry is that President Macon knew
about this opposition he knew that in
Parliament there was widespread
opposition to this and he simply you
used a mechanism called 49.3 to drive
this through effectively in the eyes of
many people subverting democracy so
another poster you might be able to
there says don't talk to me don't call
it democracy anymore call it macronism
and that I think those two things have
really inflamed anger here have led to
this series of protests of which this is
the latest one now the police have said
that they expect maybe a thousand to two
thousand people to join this who are
frankly out to cause trouble we have
seen that before so it could block Noir
people who come along and demonstrations
like this one and then separately of
course fights because of course trouble
and try to incite violence police been
very clear in their statement they want
to protect the right of people to
protest and they say that they will deal
uh harshly with uh with anybody who
causes trouble going to start in about
an hour and a quarter from here March
through middle of Paris and we will be
joining them on the journey